I'll give you all of the details. You
just fill it into a spreadsheet. So when
you run into a block where you say he
hasn't told us what to do, it is
intentional. Right? So I want you to
make a choice.
I'm not saying all choices are equally
okay. So clearly some choice are better
than others, but I want to see what
choices you make.
So today I want to continue with our
discussion of the Rio Disney theme park.
So let's see where we are. Now, we
projected the cash flows and the
earnings of the cash flows in US
dollars. We concluded that the project
was a good project cuz it's net present
value was 3.3 billion dollars.
And the IRR was higher than the cost of
capital.
Last thing we did was at the end of the
class we said, what if we'd done this
right in the in the currency in which
you'd be working with, which is
Brazilian reais? And two things
happened. One is when I switched from
dollars to reais, my discount rate went
up to almost 16%.
Why? Because I added inflation. So
again, let me be very clear. When you
switch currencies, it's not that you're
bringing in different risks or you're
looking at a different project, you're
bringing in differential inflation.
But your cash flows also increased
because the inflation was now helping
the cash flows. The net effect was zero.
If you do things right, your decision
should be the same whether you analyze a
project in US dollars, Brazilian reais,
euros,
whatever the currency you pick.
So today I want to start with a question
where the answer is pretty obvious, but
I want you to kind of go along with me.
The numbers that I came up, remember I
was a number cruncher?
Were they based on a lot of assumptions?
In fact, let's look at all of the things
that could go wrong. Could my revenues
be overestimated? What What went into my
revenues?
The number of people that come to the
theme park, what price I charge, but
this is in reais, I have no idea. Could
it be that my costs could be higher or
lower than Yeah, because I pulled the
costs from Orlando and Anaheim and who
knows what the costs will be.
What about tax rates? Right? I used a
tax rate based on what I knew at the
time of the project, but tax rates can
and do change.
Interest rates?
Do they change over time?
All the time.
Let me cut to the chase. Every single
number that I have in this forecast is
an estimate and every single number can
be wrong.
When you're fresh in this process, this
is going to drive you crazy because
you're saying, "But I could be wrong. I
could be wrong." That
And there when you think about that
uncertainty, there there are some Let's
look at the consequences. Here are some
of the things you can do.
One is you can sit and wait for the
uncertainty to go away.
So Derek, how long would you have to
wait for that to happen?
Long time, sir. Right now you might say,
"Well, we'll wait for the Trump tariffs
to pass." Guess what? There'll be
something else 2 years from now, 4 years
from now, 6 years from now. I'm sure
there are a lot of companies that
essentially are in waiting mode, waiting
for the uncertainty to clear up.
Promise, you might have to wait forever.
Second is you might say, "If I'm
uncertain, I will not take an
investment." Wait, help me out here.
Where's Wait?
He's not even in the room.
Thought I saw him come in.
Um
Somebody help me out here.
Second thing you could do is you might
say, "I will not take the investment."
If you do that, then what are you going
to end up with your company invested in
if you do not invest in anything where
you feel uncertain?
Where would you put your money?
You're going to put your money in
T-bills and wait and wait and wait.
You're going to be a money market fund.
So that's not going to work.
You can ask someone else.
Like who?
Colin Mackenzie.
Ask them, should I take the project? Not
that they have some crystal ball, but
what's the benefit of doing this?
If something goes wrong,
you blame somebody else. It's not my
fault. Let's face it, this is the
biggest reason for consulting existing.
Nobody wants to take responsibility for
their actions. It's an easy way to pass
the buck.
I'd be glad if you're a consultant, so
lucrative gig, but you're really not
bringing in some certainty into the
process.
You can ignore the uncertainty.
Are there people who can do this?
Any of you ever watch these poker
tournaments and you look at the very top
notches? I mean, these people are
borderline sociopaths.
I mean, you you you've got to be able to
turn off all your human emotions. And
there are people who can do that. Maybe
you're one of those people. You can say,
"Look, I don't care about uncertainty."
But the truth is for most of us, none of
those four choices are going to be
palatable. The question is what do we do
to deal with the fact that we're
uncomfortable? It is natural to be
uncomfortable
when you value company. This morning I
was trying to value Tesla. You know how
uncomfortable that made me feel?
Think of all the uncertainties you face.
In addition to all the electric car
stuff, you now have to bring in the
uncertainty of politics, the uncertainty
of economics. All of these play. Yes.
It's not just that the Zoom is not
working. The it's not picking up my
microphone, so unfortunately,
you know, they they've sent somebody not
picking up either my camera or my
microphone. But there's a Tell them
there'll be a second recording that's
made. I don't know whether the camera
works for that either. So for whatever
reason, the camera is shut down and the
technology is broken.
But I No, we've got to go with what we
have. Yeah?
So the question is what can you do to
make yourself be able to make a
decision? So let's go through through
some of the ways in which people have
Cuz this is as as old as time. As long
as people have had to run businesses,
they've had to deal with uncertainty.
So let's look at one of the oldest
techniques that people have used to kind
of deal with the uncertainty.
What's the big problem with this
project? It's a huge project. You spend
the money up front, 5 billion, right?
There's a lot of uncertainty about the
future.
But one of the things you might say,
"Look, I at least want to make my money
back." It's a pretty reasonable place to
start, right? Once I make the 5 billion
back, then everything else is icing on
the cake. That's technically not true.
So what do you do? You count the cash
flows till you get your money back. It's
called payback. It's been around
forever.
And when you count up the cash flows and
you look at the point in time you get
your initial investment back, it's 10.3
years. You're saying, "What do I do with
that?" There are companies that actually
have constraints on payback. They will
not take projects
which have a payback greater than X
years.
If you're a technology company,
you probably want to set a lower payback
period, right? Cuz technology can
change. It's a very simplistic way of
dealing with uncertainty, but it's one I
mean, ultimately what you're trying to
do is get yourself comfortable enough
that you can make a decision, right?
You're not paralyzed, you're not in
denial.
So look at the payback.
The second is you can discount because
remember, making your money back doesn't
make you whole again. Why? Because that
5 billion was tied up for 10 years. It
could have been in T-bills, it could
have been something else.
So the second approach actually looks at
the time value of money and looks at
when you will get your money back on a
discounted cash flow basis. Not that
much different from payback, but you're
essentially saying, "If I wait 17 years
on a discounted basis, I get my money
back." Those are big numbers, right? And
you're saying, "Well, that's a lot of
risk." But in the case of Disney with
theme parks, you might say these parks
last for 50, 60 years, it's okay.
A technology company with those payback
periods would never take this project.
So that's the first and simplest way of
dealing with uncertainty is look to see
when you make your money back.
Any questions on payback?
Let's move to the second way in which we
deal with uncertainty. The second way we
deal with uncertainty is we ask what if
questions.
And it's become so easy to ask what if
And I'll give you a story to illustrate
how difficult it used to be and why
people did not ask very many what if
questions.
I did my MBA between 1979 and 1981. For
those of you who are familiar with the
economics
of this country in 1970 That Those were
the Volker years. One of the steepest
recessions of all time.
The economy had fallen off a cliff,
inflation, they were try trying to fight
inflation. So that summer 1980, I had to
go find something to do because I needed
money.
I ended up working for a company called
Watermark.
It's I I think calling it a company
might be using the word company loosely.
It was a business. You know what they
did? They made radio shows.
Which they syndicated
to stations around the country.
The show that they made is called
American Top 40. It's still around.
In 1980, the DJ who So the way the show
worked is it's very low-tech. What they
would do is they would play down from
the top 40 songs, starting with number
40, going down to number one with a disc
jockey essentially giving you talk in
the middle, right? Talking about And
those days, you didn't you know, you
didn't know what was happening with the
stars. He would give you these little
tidbits. I you know, I ran into the star
in the gym and this is what we talked
about. And the guy who actually DJ'd the
show was a guy called Casey Kasem, at
that time a legendary DJ. And it's a
single show.
It was syndicated to 520 stations around
the country, each of whom paid a
thousand dollars a week to get the show.
It's a pretty lucrative business, right?
520 times a thousand, 520,000. I think
Casey got paid 50,000 a week or some
ridiculous amount for what he actually
did.
And this is the only show This show
business was that show.
So, they wanted to grow the business.
You can't grow the show, right? 520
stations, you've hit pretty much every
part of the country. So, they decide to
come up with an innovative concept. You
know what their innovation was?
To go back 20 years,
take a week because this week, right? Go
back 20 years to a week in 1960 because
it was 1980, go back to
take the top 40 songs from that week
and do essentially they called it
soundtrack of the '60s. So, it's
American Top 40 set back 20 years.
Incredibly incredible innovation.
They got this other legendary disc
jockey called Murray the K. At that
time, legendary disc jockeys worked at
radio stations around the country. The
people would actually tune into a
station because they liked the
Murray the K.
So, they said, you know, they were
hiring and I was desperate, so I took
the job and they said, "Your job is to
assess whether we should produce this
show."
Capital budgeting exercise, right?
So, I start off with a blank ledger
sheet.
So, I go to the CFO and say, "Can you
tell me how many stations you can sell
the show to?" He said, "I don't know,
that's why we've hired you."
Can you give me a starting what you go
talk to the marketing guy. I mean, this
was a small business. They were little
cubicles. So, marketing guy was in a
second cubicle.
I walked over to his cubicle and from
the moment he saw me, he did not like
me.
So, basically, he would act like I was
not even there and after about 2 weeks,
I said, "Look, I need something to get
started. Can you give me at least a
rough sense of how many stations you can
sell the show to?" He said, "I don't
know, 200, 300, 400, somewhere around
there."
I knew this is all I was going to
extract from the guy. So, went back to
my mini cubicle
and I got my worksheet going. Guess what
my base case number was?
200, 300, 400, so I went right down the
middle.
Base case 300. I should have made it 303
or made made it look like I knew more
than I did, but I didn't know that then.
So,
every line on this ledger sheet was like
pulling teeth.
But after about 6 weeks, I had the
entire sheet filled up. Every cell
calculated and remember that was
calculated by with a calculator and a
pencil. I finished the whole thing. I
computed net present value.
Feeling really good about myself all my
MBA coming into work with my first
corporate finance class.
And I go to the man the the the CEO's
office and again, the CEO's office was
the only one he actually had a room and
I said, "Look, I'm done
and I'd like to present
to you what I found." He said, "Let me
call in the board of directors." He call
picks up the phone, he calls his two
friends who are the board of directors,
they come in, all three of them are
sitting around.
I go through the numbers and then I hit
the climactic moment. I say, "You based
on my numbers,
I don't think you should take the show."
They look at each other and say,
"Well, what if you tried 400 stations?"
My stomach dropped.
Because remember, this is a ledger
sheet. To change 300 to 400, what do I
have to do? Go through every single cell
and I said, "Well, the NPV probably turn
positive." They said,
"Well, then do it."
I said, "Why?" He said, "We've already
decided to take the show. We just want
you to confirm it."
I thought at that moment
that this was just a small business
being unsophisticated.
But in the 40 plus years since, here's
what I've discovered. This is more the
rule than the exception. In most
companies, people decide to do something
and then
they look for justification. So, the num
So, much as we'd like to think that we
do capital budgeting and we use the
numbers to make a decision. In many
businesses, the decision gets made first
and the analysis follows.
But asking what if questions then was
doing everything from start. It took
hours to do.
I actually did it with 400 stations. It
took me a whole day.
Today, you have an Excel spreadsheet.
You put in 300 stations, you don't
compute all the numbers.
As long as you don't hard code the
numbers and here's my advice to you.
When you build Excel spreadsheets, I'm
not a financial modeler, but here's one
thing I've learned the hard way. Never
hard code any numbers into a cell.
Okay, so when you do the case, have an
input page where all the the numbers go.
Have output pages where everything is
read off the input page. That way, if
you change your mind, you're not working
through 50 cells, you're just changing
one cell.
It's become incredibly easy
to ask what if questions.
And I think it's become too easy.
Every semester for the last 20 plus
years, I've concocted these cases.
Celsius this year. I don't even remember
last year it was I think Nike apparel 2
years ago.
Last year, might be Tesla robots. So,
each year I make up this business and
you go through the process you're going
through now. You know, work in groups,
you come up with a case report and every
year I beg people, "Please, please keep
it brief
because you're not writing a novel and
I've got to go through this. And most of
the time, people listen.
But I still remember about a decade ago,
sent out this case. I don't know what
the case was that semester.
I think it was Home Depot furniture kind
of a business.
And I get these reports back and there
are, you know, 60 groups and 59 of
reports of six, seven, eight pages. They
listened to me and one has a report of
110 pages. It's always this one group
that does this. So,
"What the heck are you talking about for
110 pages?"
So, here's what they've done. They've
done 105 different scenarios on the
case. They must have had a macro running
through scenarios. Compute net present
value under each scenario, but here was
the bottom line. They get to the last
page and they say, "In 55 of these
scenarios, we got a positive net present
value.
In 50, we got a negative net present
value. We're too confused.
You make the decision."
And this I think is part of the problem
with the what ifs we run today. We think
we're going to converge on some degree
of assurance, but the more what ifs you
run, the more confused you get.
So, if you're going to run what if
analyses, which I think you will be
tempted to do on this case, I have two
pieces of advice. One,
less is more. Don't take every variable
and change it. Pick the two or three
variables that you think drive the NPV
the most.
So, you I want you to start thinking
about Celsius. See, it's of all the
assumptions I've listed, which one is
the big one? Which one's going to drive
your and focus your what ifs on that.
And second, when you present your what
if analyses, for God's sakes, don't
create 50 more exhibits with numbers.
Cuz the human mind is incapable of
dealing with those numbers. It's
mind-boggling.
Think of a creative way of presenting
those numbers in a picture. You think
that's easy?
Isn't it so charting Excel?
It's the laziest device ever, right?
I've seen charts introduced for two
numbers to compare two numbers. I don't
need a chart if you have two numbers.
You just give me the first number and
the second number, but you'll have two
big bars next to each other. Look, the
second number is bigger than the first
one. Thank you for letting me know. 250
is greater than 150.
If you want to see, you know, and I
think part of the problem is in Excel,
everything can be converted into a
chart.
If you really want to see good charting,
there's a guy called Edward Tufte. I
don't know he might be retired now. I
think he used to teach at Princeton.
And he used to teach about visually
displaying information. In fact, his
most famous book is called The Visual
Display of Information. You can get it
on Amazon for less than $10. Well worth
the money. And what he looks at are
creative ways in which people have
presented data
with pictures. And my favorite chart of
all time is somewhere in that book.
It's a chart that shows you what
happened when Napoleon decided to invade
Russia.
I don't know what it is about Russia and
and European monarchs, but every 10 or
20 years, they seem to get in their
head, "I want to invade Russia."
So, Napoleon wakes up one day, supreme
ruler, you know, and he said his
reputation, great French army and he
says, "I'm going to invade Russia."
So, the entire army takes off. See the
width of this line? That's the
Napoleon's army leaving Paris. So, the
width of that line, it's the big army.
So, they're marching through Europe. You
see, what are these little tangents?
They get distracted, invade Poland and
all, you know, other countries in the
middle.
They march and march. It takes them a
long time to get to the Russian border.
Remember, these are not cars they're
going in, they're going on horses.
Napoleon on a horse, others are
marching.
They get to the Russian border and
Moscow is still a long way away, so they
keep marching and marching. They get to
the outer limits of Moscow. The gate
is still there in Moscow. They You know,
Russians are very proud of it. They get
to that entry to Moscow and they
discover that Moscow in December is not
a nice place to be.
He says, "This is really cold.
We want to go back." So, there's the
Napo there's the French army on its way
back and as it's going back, take a look
at this. This is the temperature
that they're walking through and as
temperature is freezing, the army is
getting smaller. So, by the time you get
back
to Paris,
it's three guys carrying Napoleon and
the army is gone. This is a great chart.
There are entire books on Napoleon
invading Russia. This chart brings home
the whole story.
So, if you want to show me what will
happen to Celsius eats of the market
share and total market are different,
you have a much lesser task. You can do
it creatively.
So, it's a it's it's something I see
more and more of people thinking about
how do you,
you know, present information visually.
You know, there's um there are a couple
of programs out there where you where
actually you try to present things in
interesting graphs. The New York Times
experiments sometimes. You can see it in
some of the experiments that they're
bubble charts
where they just don't put scatter plots.
Think of creative ways of presenting
your data.
So, you can ask payback questions, you
can ask what-if questions. I'll give you
my favorite device for dealing with
uncertainty. And it's a device I could
not have used
40 years ago, 30 years ago, even 20
years ago. Maybe not even 10 years ago.
Word of Monte Carlo simulation?
First, you're familiar with Monte Carlo,
right? Europe, it's a gambling, you
know, casinos.
Monte Carlo simulation essentially take
what we do
and bring in statistics into the
process.
When you say you're uncertain about a
number,
Leon, when you say you're uncertain
about a number, help me out here. What
exactly does that mean? You say, "I am
uncertain about a number."
By the way, you can give me a number,
but say, "But I could be wrong." You ask
me how many games will the Yankees win
this season? I could hit you with a
number.
155. No, that's not going to happen.
Let's hope. But given what we have,
maybe 90 games.
Am I certain about it? Absolutely not.
But uncertainty just means there's a
range around your estimate, right?
There's a distribution. That's basically
what uncertainty means.
And for the longest time in finance and
investing, we work with point estimates.
What is point estimates? For every
number, I want your best estimate.
That's not a bad practice, but I'm
asking you for an expected value.
What if in addition I get allowed you to
give me a distribution
on that value? In other words, you say
you're uncertain, tell me how uncertain
you are.
So, what I did here was I took my Rio
Disney and I said I gave you numbers,
but you know what? I'm not that certain
about them. Remember that revenue number
I gave?
Well, I could be off by 20% in either
direction, plus or minus 20%. My base
number I believe in, but there's a
distribution.
This is called a uniform distribution.
When do you use a uniform distribution?
When you believe it's a completely
diffuse. It could be anywhere from 80 to
120 and there's no reason for you to
believe it's centered around a number.
Remember that 60% margin that I
that I had 60%
direct cost that I had for the theme
parks? Where did I get that? By looking
at Orlando and Anaheim, but this is in
Rio.
I could be completely off. I think the
60% is my best case estimate, but this
is called a triangular distribution.
It's symmetric.
Basically, that the true cost can be
anywhere from, you know,
45% to 75%.
You see, my base case is still the same,
but I'm pretty providing a distribution.
And for the country risk premium, Brazil
could get riskier or safer. If you
remember, I had 3% country risk premium,
so that too can change.
You put those distributions in. Here's
how a simulation works.
The computer goes and plucks one number
out of the revenue distribution. That
number could be higher than my base case
or lower. Let's say it's 104%. My
expected revenues are now higher. It
goes and plucks a number out of the
operating expense. Let's say it's 58%,
lower than my 60%. It goes and plucks a
number out of the country risk premium.
Let's say it's 2.8%. So, on all three I
got numbers better than my base. I
valued the project. I'm going to come up
with an NPV of 4 billion instead of 3.3
billion. I do it again
and again and again. The way this was
taught to me in my statistics class is
my statistics professor actually brought
in three big glass bowls with papers,
you know, where he'd written numbers and
he plucked one out and
if you do that, you can't do this
hundreds of times. It's time consuming.
But a computer can essentially do it in
seconds.
40 years ago to do this, though, you'd
have needed access to a mainframe
computer.
You'd have had to pay millions of
dollars running
today.
If you have Excel,
at Stern we have a program called
Crystal Ball. You have if you seen it in
passing, you say, "What the heck is it?"
Here's what Crystal Ball does. It adds
on to Excel.
And when you enter a cell, for instance,
I ask you, "What are the direct
expenses?" With Crystal Ball installed,
you can say, "My direct expenses at
cell, you can enter a number and enter a
distribution for that number, 60%
uniformly distributed."
Crystal Ball's default is it runs 10,000
simulations in a minute.
You could set it to 100,000, it'll take
it a minute and a half. You could set it
to a million, just play with it 2
minutes. And as it runs, you can see the
distribution of the net present values
show up.
You say, "What do I What do I gain by
doing this?" First, the median net
present value is 3.3 billion. Does that
look familiar? That was my NPV in the
base case, but that shouldn't surprise
you. Why? Because every distribution was
centered around my base case.
But here are the the Here's the output
from a simulation that you can use in
your actual decision.
Remember you do a best case, worst case
sometimes? It's already in here, right?
My best case is 8 and 1/2, 9 billion. My
worst case is minus 1.1 billion. It's in
there.
But you can also look at the 10th
percentile, the 20th percentile, the
30th percentile, and you can say, "Look,
you know, I'm getting a sense of how
much variation there is in this
project." You're getting a sense of how
uncertainty will play out here. I call
this facing up to uncertainty. You're
not hiding from it. You're not in
denial. You're saying, "I want to look."
That's what I plan to do in my Tesla
valuation. I'm going to make my best
case estimates, and after I'm done,
I'm going to run a simulation. And guess
what the simulation is going to show?
It's a huge range, and that's always
been the case with Tesla. But now that
you have the added politics of the
moment, you're going to get an even
wider range.
Does that bother me? No, it is reality.
And as an investor, you got to factor
that into your decision making.
Any questions on Monte Carlo
simulations?
So, you get a chance, try Crystal Ball.
The one thing I would caution you is if
your statistics is a little fuzzy,
Crystal Ball will make it clear.
And here's what I mean. When you pick a
So, the way Crystal Ball works is you
you decide to make a cell an input cell
into a distribution,
it'll ask you, "What distribution do you
want to use?" It'll give you 53
different distributions you can pick
from.
And if your statistics is fuzzy, you're
going to look at those 53 and say,
"What's an exponential distribution?
What's a log normal distribution? What's
a Bernoulli distribution?" And guess
what the only distribution that's going
to look familiar to you is if your
statistics class has become fuzzy.
You're going to find that everything is
normally distributed, because that's the
only distribution you actually
recognize. It's garbage in, garbage out
there.
If you're going to use this, at least
spend I and I have an eight-page kind of
documentation on how to pick between
distributions, kind of a speedy
run-through different kinds of
distributions. Take a look at it,
because it'll give you the tools at
least to bring simulations into play.
Incredibly powerful tool, no matter what
aspect of business you decide to go work
in, marketing, strategy. It allows you
to face up to to uncertainty and bring
it into your numbers.
So, now let's assume I'm back to you as
a decision maker. So, I've done the
simulation. I present to you with the
output, which is
your median value is about 3.3 billion,
but there's a lot of uncertainty. In
fact, there is a 12% chance, if I count
the number of times I get negative NPVs,
there's a 12% chance this project could
be a bad project.
The ball's back in your court, right?
You have a positive NPV,
but there's a 12% chance your NPV will
be negative.
So, here are the question Here are the
choices you have.
Would You can still accept the
investment, print the results out,
and put it in a folder.
Why? Because then if somebody says, "Did
you do your due diligence?" you pull it
out and you say, "Look, you know, I
Which is pure covering your rear end.
And a lot of people ask what-if
questions precisely for that reason.
That becomes the definition of due
diligence.
The second is
that you will reject the investment
because you want zero chance of net
negative net present value. This is a
very conservative strategy. There are
businesses that might adopt it.
But if you do it, you're actually double
counting risk, right?
In what way? How do you compute the NPV?
You took me expected cash flows, you
discounted them back at a risk-adjusted
discount rate.
And because you got a risk-adjusted
discount rate,
you already factored in risk. And now
you're counting in risk a second time.
So, you're saying, "Why bother then?"
Because
it's not just taking the project, right?
You got to run the project. What if you
ran the project differently, you got a
better distribution?
What one way reason you're getting
negative net present value is the cost
becomes 75% of revenues. And what if
there's a way you can
prevent that from happening by maybe
entering into pre-emptive wage contracts
where you're willing to set 63% as a
cost rather than 60%, but in return the
the the people who work for you say,
"Look, we're not going to go on strike.
We're not going to walk out."
It's a becomes a tool for you to decide
how to run the project to minimize the
downside risk and the damage to you.
So, any questions on uncertainty?
Because that's going to come up when you
do the project, you come up with an NPV
and ask you to make a decision. You're
going to have this discussion as a group
of there is this NPV. If it's positive,
of course, you say, "I'm going to
think." But there'll be somebody in the
group who says, "What if this happens?"
It's good to ask those questions, but
you still have to remember your ultimate
mission here is to make a decision.
So, let's talk about Disney Plus. That's
Disney's big new business, right?
Disney Plus was my you know
no the the history is a little strange
because this happened at the peak of
COVID. Bob Iger leaves, Bob Chapek comes
in.
And he decides to reorganize Disney from
the five divisions you saw into three
businesses.
Yeah.
The TV business is I'm so basically it's
a
And he threw all his chips on the on on
the table on the streaming business.
That was going to be what made Disney a
growth company again.
Invested billions of dollars. The
Mandalorian, as I said, became the show
that made Disney Plus
into a subscriber heaven because people
signed up because they wanted to see
that. It was almost as good as Game of
Game of Thrones for HBO. If you
remember, there were people who would
actually sign up for HBO. HBO has a very
different strategy. They didn't go with
the Netflix hundreds of millions. They
went for fewer shows, smaller audience,
presumably more loyalty.
So, Disney Plus was built up, but
basically it's a it's a it's a division
that's sucking up huge amounts of money.
There's no way Disney Plus can compete
with Netflix
on content.
Number of shows. Cuz Netflix just makes
shows, throws them up against the wall,
hopes something sticks, right? 20 shows
a day. Disney Plus can't do that. No
entertainment business in history's been
able to do that.
And that's why I think Netflix has
broken the entertainment business.
Cuz by making that many shows with
Amazon Prime
on the side, they've essentially broken
the business. Made it almost impossible
for traditional content companies
to exist in that business.
But that's a story for a different day.
Disney Plus Disney believes it's going
to be one of the survivors from this
broken business. So, Disney Plus is the
place they're going.
So, if you look at a new Disney Plus
show, let's say you work at Disney.
You're the person in charge of Disney
Plus. You know you got to come up with
new shows to keep the subscribers on.
Could be an Avengers show, it could be a
Star Wars show. Basically, those are the
two big contributors to new shows. And I
come to you with a new show and I say,
"We want to make the show." Remember,
this is not a cheap exercise.
You know, even The Mandalorian cost
15-20 million. Look at Daredevil, 35
million. Eight shows, you're looking at
essentially a 300-350 million dollars
spend just on the content. Not not to
mention the advertising and the other
stuff. It's like a half a billion dollar
investment.
So, how do we analyze investment? We
look at what you invest, right? Half a
billion. But then we have to estimate
the expected cash flows. And already you
can see the struggle you're going to
have
when it's a Disney Plus show.
If you were making a show for a for
traditional broadcasting, where did the
revenues come from?
You made a show for ABC.
Traditionally, you made the show, it
cost you money.
But your money came from
advertising. So, if you had high
ratings, you sold more advertising.
Disney Plus doesn't sell advertising.
There's a version I know that sells, but
the bulk of it is just subscribers.
And the only way you justify the shows
is we don't make it, we will either lose
subscribers or the positive spin is
we'll get more subscribers.
That's tough to measure, right? Cuz when
somebody adds Disney Plus,
nobody asked them, "Did you add Disney
Plus because you wanted to see
Daredevil?" You got to make that leap of
faith of that's why they did it.
It's incredibly
mushy in terms of how you determine the
benefits.
Which also means that you can explain
why Netflix is doing what it's doing,
which is they have no idea whether a
show creates additional subscribers or
not. They throw It's a terrible way to
run a business.
I describe Netflix as a hamster on a
wheel where you can't really get off the
wheel because you're training people to
expect 10-20 new shows. But basically,
that's something I wanted to think about
is when you have a business like this
one, increasingly in platform
businesses, you're spending money, but
there's no direct relationship to your
revenues.
How do you measure incremental revenues?
Eventually, I think streaming
you know, show streaming platforms are
going to have to figure this out cuz we
can't keep doing what we're doing, which
is make the shows, hope it works, assume
that the numbers are what they are
because of the shows when in fact
there's no direct way of connecting
them.
Technology might help them because they
might see what you're watching, why you
drop, maybe there'll be more information
you get when you sign up or you drop,
but it's coming. It has to come.
Otherwise, it's impossible to have
discipline in investing.
So, we looked at two Disney projects,
very different. A theme park and a show.
You can already see within Disney they
will have very different
characteristics.
And if you think about what discount
rate would I apply for Disney Plus, it's
going to be very different than the
discount rate you would apply
for a Disney theme park.
So, I'm going to move to a third
project. This is a project from an old
economy company, Vale, an iron ore
mining company. And I'm going to do this
entire project analysis in equity terms.
Let me explain what I mean by that. If
you go back and look at the Disney theme
park analysis,
I computed the operating income on the
theme park. I ignored interest expenses.
I looked at free cash the cash flows
you'd make before So, if there are debt
payments, I completely ignore them,
right? I looked at cash flows before
debt payments.
And when I discounted those cash flows,
I used the cost of capital because it's
no money's coming from both debt and
equity. And I computed an NPV.
I took a tangent where I computed an
accounting return, but the return I
computed was return on invested capital,
after-tax operating income as a
percentage of invested capital.
And I compared it to the cost of
capital.
So, in an equity approach, I'm going to
take a slightly different tack. I'm
going to focus just on the equity
investors.
When I look at earnings now, I'm going
to focus on net income, not operating
income, income after interest expenses.
When I look at what returns they make,
I'm going to look at net income as a
percent of book value of equity, not
invested capital.
And I'm going to compare it to the cost
of equity.
When I do my cash flows, those cash
flows are going to be after debt
payments.
So, here's the project. There's lots of
information on this page. Let me
summarize what it looks like.
First, this mine will require an initial
investment of 1.25 billion over the and
you know,
and the production capacity will be 8
million tons.
How do you know? Because some geologist
came in and said there's iron ore there.
You're trusting them. There's 8 million
tons.
1.25 billion.
That investment is going to be
depreciated down over 10 years using
some accelerated depreciation method.
So, more depreciation up front, less
later. Down to a salvage value of 250
million. Already I'm leading to a
different end game here than in the
Disney theme park, right?
The Disney theme park, I estimated cash
flows to the next 10 years. And what
happens after year 10? It continues as a
theme park.
Why am I not making that assumption
here? Why can't this iron ore mine keep
continuing as as an iron ore mine?
Cuz the mine
there's no more iron ore in the ground,
right? So, this is a finite project. You
can't just make up terminal values when
the game is over.
So, in this case, at the end of 10
years, I have salvage value. I sell off
equipment, what's left, for 250 million.
The mine will start production midway
through the year. And it's going to take
a while to build in. So, you know,
you won't produce 8 million tons next
year. And this is a reality with a lot
of natural resource. It takes a while to
build up to full capacity.
And as you do that, you need to get a
price
per ton.
The price per ton of iron ore at the
time I did this analysis is $100 a ton.
I could make predictions about what that
price will be. Be optimistic, but I
don't want to do that because I want to
decide on this on this mine based on
what I know about the iron ore price
today. So, what I'm going to do is
assume that price stays constant
in real terms. Inflation terms, of
course, it's going to go up at the
inflation rate. $100 per ton. So, that's
going to be the price all the way
through.
The variable cost of production is
expected to be $45 a ton. So, remember,
the price is 100, the cost is 45. But
there's also a fixed cost of 125 million
every year from from operating the mine.
Everything is locked into the inflation
rate of 2%.
Why? Because I want to keep things
simple. I mean, clearly I could have
brought in complexities here, but I'm
keeping things simple. There will be a
working capital requirement of 20% and
the investments have to be made at the
beginning of each year. Why does that
matter? Because in terms of timing, that
means to get the working capital going
for year two, I need to bring it in at
the end of year one. Remember, the
beginning of year two and the end of
year one are essentially the same point
in time. It's December 31st versus
January 1st, so that's why that matters.
And finally, the corporate tax rate is
34%.
So, I've pretty much given you the
details, but since I'm focused on
equity, I also have to tell you where
I'm getting the bit 1.25 billion. The
Disney theme park, I never told you
where the 5 billion came from, whether
it came from debt or equity.
Here, I have to be explicit. They are
going to borrow a half a billion out of
the 1.25 billion.
And I also have to tell you what the
terms of that debt are. It's going to be
a term loan. What's a term loan? You
basically pay it off in equal
installments over the next 10 years.
What's the other type of, you know,
other common type of loan? You can have
a term loan, which is what your home
mortgage is.
But what's the other type of loan?
What's a corporate bond? Is a corporate
bond term loan?
No, you pay only interest each year, and
then you pay the face value at the end.
It's a balloon payment loan. So,
basically, I have to give you the
details. Why? Because you need to figure
out what your debt payments will be each
year. In this case, your debt payment is
exactly the same every year. Why?
Because it is a term loan. That's how
term loans work.
But,
the portion of that payment that's
interest, the portion that's principal,
will change over time.
Now, if any of you get a home mortgage,
you will see this actually in your
mortgage statement. The year that you
take the mortgage, if it's a 30-year
mortgage, almost the entire payment
will be interest. If you stay all the
way through year 30, which very few
people do, by the time you get to year
30, your total payment will be the same,
it will be almost all entirely
principal.
So, you're going to see that pattern
here. You basically have the interest
expense decrease over time, the
principal portion increase, but the
total pay Why do I care, though? The
total payment stays the same. Why do I
care how much is interest and how much
is principal?
They're both cash outflows.
So, what difference does it make whether
it's interest or principal? It doesn't
matter.
No, but why do I care what that interest
is?
Right? Total pay It's a cash flow, so
what does it matter?
Tax Because I'm allowed to deduct
interest expenses for tax purposes, but
I'm not allowed to deduct principal
payments. Already, you can see why doing
cash flows equity is messier, right? Cuz
I've got to break up into interest and
principal. But that's the reason I'm
doing it.
So, I've given you the details of the
project. I've given you the details of
how much I'm going to borrow.
The question is what discount rate
should I use, assuming I can get to the
cash flows,
So, here are Vale's numbers for the
different businesses, cost of equity,
cost of capital.
I did my cash flows entirely in US
dollars. The inflation rate you saw was
US dollar inflation rate. Why? Because
it's a commodity company. It's much
easier to do in dollars anyway.
So, I want to use a dollar discount
rate, but
given that I'm estimating cash flows
after debt payments,
I want to use a cost of equity.
Cost of equity here in dollar terms is
11.13%. I want to make sure it's the
cost of equity for a I'm following
exactly the same principle that I did
for Disney,
which is where I used the theme park
cost of capital. Here, I'm using the
iron ore cost of equity, because it's an
iron ore project, and I'm looking at
cash flows after debt payments.
So, 11.13% is going to be my discount
rate.
So, let's look at the numbers. I know
there are a lot of numbers in the table,
but let me at least give you the big
picture in what I'm trying to do.
For the next 10 years, what do I do? I
extract iron ore from the ground, and
I've told you how much because you're
building up to that 8 million tons.
I sell it at the prevailing market
price, which I've assumed to be in
constant dollar terms $100, but because
there's inflation, the price goes up at
the inflation rate. So, that's the
number going up 2% a year.
You multiply the tons by the price, you
get the total revenues. I subtract the
variable cost. The variable cost is
always $45 a ton adjusted for inflation,
so it's always going to keep up with the
revenues. But the fixed cost, 125, just
goes with the inflation rate.
I subtract out the depreciation from the
initial investment, I come up with the
operating income. If with Disney, I
stopped there, right?
Here, I keep going because I want to
keep bringing in the interest expense
to come to taxable income. That's why
interest expenses matter. I compute the
tax at 34%, I've got my net income. My
end game here is net income because I'm
focused on the equity investors in the
company.
To divide that net income, I start with
invested capital. So, it looks again
like I'm doing exactly what I did with
the Rio theme park. I take CAPEX,
subtract depreciation, but here I also
subtract out the debt outstanding from
that invested capital. What does that
give me? It gives me the book value of
equity.
When you've decided to go the equity
route, you've got to wear blinders.
Everything is about equity investors.
You're looking at net income, earnings
to equity investors, book value of
equity, which is what equity is invested
in.
You divide net income by the book value
of equity, you get what's called the
return on equity.
Return on invested capital, you look at
operating income and invested capital.
Return on equity, you look at net income
and book equity. My average return on
equity or for this theme park or for
this uh for this iron ore mine is 31%,
but here, you look at the ROE column,
notice how steeply it climbs.
Why is that happening? Why is the return
When I did this for Disney, the thing
the return on invested capital didn't
explode out. It went up, but it didn't
go to 50, 60%. What's happening here
that's making the return on equity so
high
by the time I get to year seven, year
eight, year nine, and year 10?
Constantine, what do you think it's
doing?
Sorry.
I didn't hear you. What did you say?
But but carry that through. It's not
just that. What's happening to my asset
because it's a finite life?
And why is my equity going down?
It's a finite life asset, right? So, I'm
depreciating the asset. So, what happens
to the book value over time? It
decreases. In the case of the Rio theme
park, remember I put my money back in
cuz I wanted to That's what's So, if you
have a finite life project, I would
safely predict that older projects will
look amazing
on a return on equity basis, not because
they're amazing projects, but because
you've written down your money so much
that there's so little It's the
denominator that's essentially
imploding. The net income is not
soaring,
but the book value of equity is getting
so tiny.
So, it's a feature, not a bug, of
accounting return on equity that older
projects will always look better on a
return on equity basis
than younger projects.
And and to make the comparison, that is
higher than my cost of equity for iron
ores of 11.1. So, on an accounting
basis,
this project looks good.
But as with the Rio Disney theme park,
we know accounting returns are not that
good. So, I'm going to try to compute
the cash flows. Before I do that,
though, I'm going to take the tangent
just as I did for accounting return on
capital.
Remember there, we computed return on
invested capital for the entire company.
I think with Disney, we came up with
12.81%,
higher than the cost of capital, and we
said it's a very rough measure of is
this company taking good investments? I
could do the same thing with return on
equity. I could compute the return on
equity, but here I would compare it to
the cost of equity for the company. And
if you look at Disney, their return on
equity in 2013 was 14.62%, net income
divided by book equity.
Much higher than the cost of equity. I'm
getting confirmation of what I got with
the return on capital.
I'm I've asked you to do this for your
company when you on your project, and
when you do it,
for many of your companies, you'll get
confirmation. For some of your
companies, you might actually get
divergent signals. In other words, one
measure will say this company's taking
good projects, the other might say it
takes bad projects, and I want you to
think about why that might happen, cuz
you will run into this for some of your
companies. And it's an accounting
return, and the answer might lie in how
we computed the numbers and what goes
into those numbers,
So, as with the Rio Disney theme park,
here I'm going to go from net income to
incremental cash flow.
Process is very similar. Add back
depreciation, subtract CAPEX, subtract
change in working capital,
but there's one additional line item you
have now that you didn't have with free
cash flow to the firm. Remember, now
you're looking at equity cash flows.
You've got to pay the loan back.
There's principal payments come into
play here. You subtract those out. And
in year 10,
you wrap up all your loose ends. The
project is done, put in the salvage
value. Your working capital, you're
going to get it back. In fact, if you
look at the working capital number,
these numbers for the first 9 years,
working capital drains your cash flows.
You're saying, "Why is there a working
capital right now?" Year zero is not a
year, it's actually today.
That's my working capital for year one.
Remember, I have to invest at the start
of the year.
But at the end of year 10, I get all of
my working capital back.
If that sounds like a mechanical thing,
this is like you're going out of
business sale, right? So, if you ignore
working capital in year 10, you're
essentially taking your inventory,
throwing it in the streets, and saying,
"I'm done. Therefore, I don't care."
You take call your people, "Oh, you
money? So, don't pay me.
I'm done with the project." It doesn't
work that way. You're trying to get your
working capital back when you salvage a
project. So, when you get to the end of
a finite life project, tie up loose
ends.
Get the salvage value on what you can
sell.
Get as much of your working capital back
as you can.
And generally, it's a good idea to get
your entire working capital back simply
for a mechanical reason. If you sell to
a number other than your book value,
you'll have a tax consequence,
right?
So, basically, I'm ignoring that, and I
have my free cash flows to act the cash
flow to equity on this project. So,
after debt payments every year.
I discount those cash flows back at my
cost of equity, 11.13%.
What I get is net present value, 304
million. Confirming what my accounting
returns told me, this is a good project
based on equity cash flows and the cost
of equity, the net present value is 304
million.
Any questions about equity? This is, I
think, one of the things that even
people who are seasoned in cash flows,
sometimes they can't do the divide
between firm cash flows and equity cash
flows.
As long as you stay with in your lane,
you say, "I'm focused equity. All I care
about is equity." Everything will play
out. Now, but mistakes often happen
because you go back and forth across
that line.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, when you do the accounting
returns, steer away from time value,
steer away from waiting because the only
way you can do a weighted average, and
I'll give you a very simple way in which
you can compute it. Add up the net
income across the next 10 years, add up
the book value of equity. It's an
aggregated number. It's probably a
better number than taking that simple
average. So, if that's what you mean by
weighted average, it is, in fact, a
better way of computing return equity
for a project with a 10-year or 15-year
life.
You don't even have to divide, right? If
you take the total net income over the
next 10 years and the total book value
of equity,
it'll already be a number, so you don't
have to divide by 10. It's already It's
an aggregated return on equity for the
entire project over the lifetime. And
it's usually more stable, because
otherwise with projects like this, those
last year numbers become so
astronomically high that when you
compute the average, they just pull the
average up, right? You get a 300% ROE in
year 10.
Could have a terrible project, but it
basically pulls up the return equity for
the project, right?
Now, this basically is that net present
value profile, where essentially I took
those cash flows, changed the discount
rate. My internal rate of return for
this project is in excess of 17%. Is
that good enough? Yeah, my cost of
equity is 11%.
This is a good project on an accounting
return basis, an NPV basis, and an IRR
basis.
Here again, I'm going to ask a what-if
question. I did everything in US
dollars, right?
How did that play out? 2% inflation
rate.
In my price, 2% inflation rate in my
cost. Could I have done everything in
real terms?
Now, tell me, what would I What would be
different if I did everything in real
terms? First, my 11.13%
cost of equity was a US dollar cost of
equity, right? Roughly speaking,
what's my real cost of equity going to
be?
The inflation rate in US dollars is 2%.
11.13% is a US dollar cost of equity.
I'm going to take the 2% off. My real
cost of equity is going to be about
9.13%.
You say that's bad. No, that's good. The
discount rate is lower. But remember,
when I do my cash flows, I now have to
take inflation out. So, the price I will
use for iron ore every year for the next
10 years is going to be $100 every year.
There's going to be no inflation effect.
You can trust me on this or actually
work through the numbers. Your net
present value will be exactly the same
if you take the inflation rate out of
both your numerator and your
denominator.
Kind of a confirmation of what we found
with currencies. Inflation that is the
wild card, and as long as you deal with
it consistently, it doesn't matter
whether you do things in nominal terms
or real terms,
Now, when you look at this project, the
things you're worried about are not the
kinds of things you worry about with a
real Disney theme park. There, you're
worried about what I think of as
company-specific, project-specific
things, which is how much will it cost
me to sell snacks on the theme park?
Will No, the tourists come into the
When you look at an iron ore project,
you You know what the big number that
drives the value at? It's the price of
per ton of iron ore.
I used $100.
But you know what the normalized the
average price was going back a century
on inflation-adjusted basis? It's about
$50 to $60.
What pushed it up to $100? China.
China, between 2003 and 2016, screwed up
every commodity price this is cycle
because it pushed up because the
infrastructure they were building
required so much, you know, iron ore and
steel.
So, you can already see the worry you
have, right? If you're in at Vale, you
look at this project with a $100 iron
ore price, you're okay. But if that
price becomes 90 or 80 or 70, you very
quickly see the net present value turn
neg- In fact, if the iron ore price is
less than $90,
your net present value is negative.
Your IRR becomes less than the cost of
equity. So, file that away. You know, so
Second, it is also affected by exchange
rates. In this case, the exchange rate
between the US dollar and the Canadian
dollar, and here's why.
The iron ore mine is in Canada. All your
costs are in Canadian dollars.
You sell your iron ore into a
dollar-based market.
As the dollar as the Canadian dollar
strengthens versus the US dollar,
right? You have a strong Your costs will
go up. Your revenues are not So, your
margins are going to get worse. So, if
the Canadian dollar weakens, you're in
good shape. The Canadian dollar
strengthens. So, there are two big macro
risks you have. One is what will happen
to iron ore prices. The second is what
will happen to exchange rates.
But those are macro risks. Can you
protect yourself against those risks?
First, let's take the exchange rate
risk. If you're worried about the
Canadian dollar getting stronger or
weaker, what can you do to kind of
protect yourself? This is the most
protectable macro risk out there, right?
You can use forwards, you can use
options, you can use derivatives. You
can hedge against exchange rate risk.
What about iron ore prices? Can you
hedge against that as well? Can you lock
it?
Hey, there's a forward market.
Commodity companies can lock in their
prices.
Sounds like a great deal, right? So, I
have a practical question. Given that
you can hedge against this risk, let's
take each of the risks. Okay. You could
go out and hedge against iron ore risk.
What does that mean? You lock in the
price today
based on the forward market.
That's good, right? It makes your
revenues more predictable.
You think they should do it, though?
I'm asking a more general question.
Should all companies hedge hedge against
all price risk? Should gold mining
companies hedge against gold price risk?
Play it out in your mind as an investor
in the company and tell me whether this
is good or bad. What do you want?
When you When you invest in Exxon Mobil,
first you had to overcome all those
concerns you had about climate change.
But let's say you got there and you
invest in Exxon Mobil.
Why are you investing in Exxon Mobil?
Because you like their management?
Now, what's the reason you invest?
Because you think oil prices will go up.
You're making a bet on oil prices. Let's
say Exxon Mobil now goes and hedges
its oil price risk.
Oil prices go up by 30%. You're happy at
home saying, "I made the right bet."
Then you check your stock price. You
say, "Hey, what's happened here? Nothing
seems to have happened."
Investors invest in commodity companies
because they're making a bet on
commodity prices. The worst thing a
commodity company can do is go out and
hedge against that risk because that
undercuts your reason
for investing in the
first place.
Barrick, which is one of the leading
gold mining companies in the world, did
this in the 1980s, and its entire
management team lost their jobs
because gold prices went up, and
Barrick's stock price stayed flat.
Investors said, "What the heck
happened?" They said, "We hedged against
risk."
No, we don't want you to.
Not all risk should be hedged. I'm going
to give you a flowchart, and if it's a
output risk, you have to be particularly
careful because investors are betting on
your company based on the output risk.
See, there are two things where lumber
plays out. One is the companies that
make lumber. There's lumber prices.
There are companies for whom lumber is a
cost.
The answer is going to be different
depending on who you ask about. So, if
you are a furniture company, and lumber
is a cost, and this is a hugely volatile
item, I think there's an argument to be
made for hedging that risk because
otherwise, how do you decide how much
furniture to make, right? But if you are
the lumber producing company,
remember, the price is an expected
price. It can go up or down. It's not
like you can say there's an 80% chance
of it going up and 20% going down. It
is, in fact, already found its steady
state. I would give the same advice for
a lumber producing company as well,
unless it has a lot of debt.
You see why that might play out?
If you have a lot of debt, one of your
concerns is the price drops, there's no
recovering back because there's no cycle
you're going to because you're going to
go out of business.
So, maybe if you have a lot of debt and
you worry about that downside risk, you
might step in and say, you know, So, if
you're a shale oil company with a lot of
debt,
there's an argument that you might want
to hedge at least some oil price risk so
you don't go bankrupt if oil prices go
to $50 a barrel. So, that's the
exception to the rule. In general, you
got to be very cautious as a commodity
company hedging your output risk.
What about exchange rate risk? It's the
most hedged risk in the world.
You know how much money companies spend
hedging exchange rate risk? It seems
like it a freebie almost. There's so
many ways to do it.
By hedging exchange rate risk, what do
you gain as a company? How does it play
out in your numbers?
Your costs are more predictable, right?
Your earnings are going to be more
stable. And if you are a company telling
the story, the banker selling you the
exchange rate protection, how does the
story play out? You're more stable
earnings, investors will pay a higher
multiple of your earnings, you'll be
worth more.
Complete lie. You know why?
Cuz there's zero
evidence to indicate that having more
stable earnings by hedging exchange rate
risk translates to a higher P/E ratio.
Say, "Why aren't investors rewarding
me?"
If your investor is BlackRock
or Fidelity, which is often the case,
and they own 100 companies, all of which
are exposed to exchange rate risk.
Remember, exchange rate risk cuts in
both directions, right? 50 of your
companies are helped by a stronger
dollar, 50 are hurt.
No, in their portfolio, what happens to
exchange rate risk? It goes away without
spending any money.
What are you doing? If each of these 100
companies now goes and hedges, the only
people who benefit are the people
selling you these products.
If you are a company with diversified
investors,
I would actually argue let the other
risk go. In fact, I think far too much
risk is hedged against.
We talk about why people might do it,
why managers might choose to do it even
though though there is no payoff for
shareholders, but
think like a manager, think of why
hedging risk makes your life easier,
even though shareholders don't get a
benefit. But if you ask me, what is the
payoff to shareholders? It's tough to
find any.
Now, if this mine were in Brazil rather
than in Canada,
maybe there's a case
for hedging this exchange rate risk
because if it's so volatile that it can
tip you into default if the wrong thing
happens. Maybe then. So, already you can
see should if if a manager asks you,
"Should I hedge?"
The answer is going to be nuanced. I'm
going to give you the framework I use
whenever somebody and because I get this
question all the time. There is In fact,
it's one of those things where I look at
the research and say, "How come people
are not answering questions like this?"
In academic research, it's almost like
it's too pragmatic a question. Should I
hedge?
Let's play it out.
Now, what is So, if you're if you're if
you ask me,
"Should I hedge?" The first question I'm
going to ask you is is there a cost to
hedging?
If there's no cost, what should you do?
Hedge away.
Retail firms hedge against location
risk. You know what I mean by location
risk? If you are a retailer with a
single store, you worry about location.
If the highway moves in the other
direction, you might lose all your you
know, customers. But if you are a
retailer opening stores across the
country, location risk gets averaged
out. A Walmart doesn't think about any
individual location risk cuz it averages
out.
That's risk you're getting rid of. So,
in the course of operations, you managed
to hedge away risk, all the more power
to you.
But if there is a cost to hedging, then
I have some questions. First is, what is
the benefit to hedging? And don't show
me that banking earnings per share being
more stable. That doesn't help me.
You got to show me something more
tangible.
It can either be that, you know, you get
some discount rate effects that people
reward you with a lower discount, maybe
a lower cost of debt, maybe bankers will
lend you money at a lower rate if you
hedge. I want to see how much this
benefit is so I can weigh it off. Maybe
there's a cash flow benefit. Maybe you
get a bigger tax benefit by hedging and
showing more stable income over time.
Or maybe as a manager, you make better
decisions if I let you hedge. You know
what I mean by that? As a manager, you
might be one of those types, you know,
who gets really stressed out when
there's a lot of risk, so you go into
So, you say, "If you let me hedge, I'll
make better choices." And if you carry
that through,
but show me the benefits. I'm not just
going to let you hedge because you show
my earnings are more stable.
Or your argument can even be made in
terms of pricing arguments. If you can
show me that companies that hedge trade
at a higher multiple of earnings, I'm
willing to listen, but I need to see the
benefits.
But if there are benefits that exceed
the cost, then I have a follow-up
question.
Can your marginal investors hedge this
risk cheaper than you can? And that's
where the BlackRocks and the Vanguards
come in, right?
If you are a global company held by big
global investors, I don't think you have
any business hedging any risk.
If you're a small company which is
closely held, the owner owns 30% of the
company, his or her wealth is tied up in
the company,
I think there's an argument for hedging
cuz your wealth could go down the drain.
You don't have the benefit of
diversification. That diversification
argument we used earlier is going to
kick in here. And whether you should
hedge or not will depend on what kind of
business you're you are and how much of
your wealth is tied up in it.
So, you own a private business, you
probably should hedge.
Right? Your entire wealth is tied up in
the business, you're not diversified.
You're publicly traded company's a
manager. I know it makes you sleep
better at night,
but I would think medication for that is
cheaper than the hedging cost.
So, maybe I will pay for that medication
so you can sleep better at night,
but don't use your interest as a reason
for me hedging away risk that trouble
you.
Any questions on hedging in general?
Let's talk about acquisitions. I've
never understood why when we teach
finance, we teach capital budgeting, and
then we talk about, you know, 15
sessions later we get to M&A.
What does that do? First, it carves out
an exception, right? An M&A is not a
capital budgeting project. In what
universe is it not a capital budgeting
project?
An acquisition is a gigantic project.
Play it out. What's the initial
investment when you do an acquisition?
It's what you pay for the target
company, right? That becomes the initial
investment.
What are your expected cash flows? They
come from the cash flows of the target
company with two
qualifiers. One is
that if you can change the way the
target company is run. Remember, you now
own it, maybe your cash flows can be
higher. That's called the value of
control.
The second is that maybe by combining
the two companies, you get cash flows
you would not have got otherwise, which
is synergy. Still cash flows.
So, acquisitions basically look very
much like traditional capital budgeting
with that added qualifier of control and
synergy.
So, here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to start with and and the
principles on what discount rate to
apply are exactly the same. The discount
rate should reflect the risk of your
project, in this case the target
company, and the mix of debt net that
that company can carry on its own, not
what you come up with in the
acquisition.
So, here's the project that I'm going to
look at.
Tata Motors is one of the companies
we've been looking through all the
classes. It's a traditional automobile
company.
It's looking at Harman Audio. You know,
it's high-end
audio systems.
Why? Partly because, you know, Tata
Motors wants to bring in another
company, but partly because it wants to
use the audio systems in its cars hoping
to sell more cars, make them more
attractive. There's synergy, there's
talk of synergy. We're going to try to
put a number on it.
But in the initial analysis today, I
want to value Tata Motors
uh I want to value Harman Audio to Tata
Motors.
So, here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to first do my valuation entirely
in US dollars. Why do you think I chose
US dollars rather than Indian rupees?
Purely pragmatic. Harman Audio is a US
company. All of its numbers are already
in dollars. Most of its revenues are
outside India. I could do it in rupees
if I wanted, but that would just make my
life more difficult. I'm going to do it
in US dollars. Why does it matter?
Because my risk-free rate will now be a
US T-bond rate.
For the beta, I used the beta of
electronic companies, not the beta of
automobile companies.
You see why? Same reason we used for the
Rio Disney, the theme park cost of
capital, beta of electronic companies.
That beta is going to play out in my
cost of equity. For the equity risk
premium, guess which companies
operating exposure I looked at?
I looked at Harman Audio's exposure, and
it is, you know, 27% US, 34% Germany,
19% rest of Europe, but the remaining
19% from Asia. Weighted average, 6.13%.
For the debt ratio and the cost of debt,
I assumed that Harman's existing debt
ratio would continue
because that's what they can afford to
borrow.
Here's a trap that many people who look
at acquisitions fall into. They look at
how an acquisition is all
funded to actually come up with the debt
ratio.
And here's why that will that's a
dangerous thing to do.
Can you acquire a company entirely with
debt?
Sure.
If I follow your reasoning that debt
ratio should come from how I acquired
the company, what should the cost of
capital for that acquisition be? It's
100% debt,
it'll be the cost of debt, which is like
what, 3%?
In case of Disney, it's 2.4%. You really
want to take by they buy a company with
a 2.4% required return?
So, what you use on an acquisition as
debt and equity is completely
irrelevant. It's what the target company
can carry.
So, in that In this case, that's about,
you know, it's it's not much debt. They
don't they're not a highly levered
company. 7.39% debt to cap, about an 8%
debt to equity.
I used that to come up with the levered
beta and a cost of equity. And overall,
the dollar cost of capital for Harman
Audio is 9.67%.
I want to emphasize that if I hadn't
told you about the acquisition, if you
were analyzing just Harman Audio, your
cost of capital would be 9.6. There's
nothing of Tata Motors in this number,
right?
And there shouldn't be.
Tata Motors is the acquiring company.
This is the target company. This is the
target company's cost of capital.
To estimate my cash flows,
I'm going to you know, keep this simple
because I don't want to make this an
entire valuation exercise. I start with
the operating income that Harman Audio
had in the most recent year. So, these
were actual numbers. Harman Audio is a
publicly traded company.
And then I did exactly what I did in the
project. To convert go from earnings to
cash flows, what do I need to do? I need
to first bring in a tax, right?
Then I had to bring in CapEx and
depreciation and working capital, but
now I'm looking at the entire company,
not a project. But actually, it's
easier. The The statement of cash flows
gave me that. The The cash flow that I'm
going to use will reflect the 18.21%
effective tax rate they paid during the
year. And the CapEx and depreciation I
pulled right off the statement of cash
flows. So, this is a company that is a
moderate growth company that's
reinvesting money. And I'm estimating
what the cash flows will be after
reinvestment, but before debt payments.
So, basically, I'm staying with the
pre-debt cash flow.
To keep things simple, I'm going to
assume that the company is in stable
growth already. Why? Because otherwise,
I'll be putting out growth for the next
10 years. I don't want to go into that
exercise. It's a mature company.
Growing at roughly 2.75%. That's
actually my risk rate. I will talk a
little bit later about why that is a
good proxy for growth forever.
2.75% growth. My cash flows next year
are going to be about 167
million dollars. I've got a cost of
capital. I've got expected cash flows
next year. I've got a growth rate.
Put those numbers in, the value that I
get for for Harman Audio is about 2.5
billion dollars. Expected cash flow next
year
divided by cost of capital minus the
growth rate.
I have a problem. You know what the
problem is? The market cap for the
company is actually about
5.4 billion. And if I use my estimated
value for this company, the value that I
get for the equity is 2.6 billion.
If I stopped right there and said,
"Should Tata Motors buy Harman Audio?"
What's your answer going to be?
Uh it's a terrible
And if you take the difference, that's a
net present value of minus 3 billion.
But guess what you're going to run into
at Tata Motors. They're going to say,
"But you haven't considered
synergy."
A little later, next class, I'm going to
bring in synergy. It's not magic. I'm
going to say, "Okay, tell me what the
synergy is. I'm not going to let you use
it as a buzzword to explain away the 3
billion dollar negative net present
value. What's the synergy? How many more
cars can you sell? Where will you sell
them?" We will value synergy explicitly.
And already, you can see what synergy
has to be worth for this to be a good
investment. It's got to be worth more
than 3 billion dollars.
And if you can show me it's there,
I'll go along.
But don't just tell me it's a plug
variable to explain away the difference
between what you pay and what something
is worth.
So, you think about it. We've done four
projects, right?
Disney theme park, cash flows of the
firm, pre-debt cash flows, cost of
capital.
Then we went to Disney Plus, a streaming
show.
And we kind of threw up our hands and we
don't know what to do here because there
is no explicit revenue earnings cash
flows. It takes the form of number of
subscribers. So, if you're Disney Plus
and you're promoting a show, you need a
better way of monitoring what's
happening because of the show.
I think the only time I've actually been
able to see this effect play out in
numbers, there are two times. One was in
the Game of Thrones where HBO was
actually reporting that the number of
subscribers based purely on because
remember, HBO at that time, this was the
show. It wasn't like they had 50 shows
like Netflix, right? So, there any
change in the subscriber numbers came
directly from the next Game of Thrones
episode.
The second scenario where I was able to
do this was when Lionel Messi
signed for for Miami last year.
Or was it 2 years ago?
You're saying, "What's that got to do
with streaming?"
What's that?
And nobody was watching it,
unfortunately, because
very few people
with the day when Messi played that
season, it doubled the number of people
who signed up. It's extra on Apple Plus.
Your regular subscription doesn't cover
it. 79 dollars and 95 cents a year. The
reason I know it so precisely is my
son-in-law is a soccer fan, and this is
my annual Christmas gift to him.
I don't know how much he appreciates it
or doesn't. It's an easy gift to find.
But that signing of Messi, you could see
caused the number of subscribers to
almost double that year. So, does Lionel
Messi have an effect? Maybe he's not the
greatest soccer player anymore,
but he clearly can bring in numbers into
the stadiums, and it's showing up as
streaming plus numbers. So,
No. But the problem with Netflix and
Disney is there's too much stuff going
on for you to isolate the effect of any
show,
So, I'm going to stop there. I know I
never end early, but I don't want to
start. But next session, when we start,
we're going to talk about side costs and
side benefits.
I would recommend that you start reading
ahead that section or looking at the
slides because it might help you on the
Cell C Seeds case because there are side
costs and side benefits. I don't want to
be mysterious. What's one of the big
side costs of taking this this this
project?
Is it logistics investment, right? Where
you run out of storage capacity earlier.
Think through what it means, right? And
how do we ask the question, "What will
happen if I take the project? What will
happen if I don't take the project?"
Work through each and look at the
difference because that's going to allow
you to answer that question.
So, I will see you on Monday.
Yep.
Makes more sense, yeah.
That definitely makes more sense.
Take care.
Yep.
Why would you ever want to use a mixed
beta? Give me the reason. There's one
segment of the case where you might use
a mixed beta.
But everything else, there's not. So,
tell me what the argument is for a mixed
beta.